the liberal media urging the democratic
party to break away from the woke in a
last-ditch effort to save the party's
fortunes before the midterm elections a
new article says the democrats need to
wake up and take on radical activists in
the party before it's too late the
warnings come on the heels of jill biden
apologizing after comparing hispanic
people
to
tacos so uh tyrus they say go woke go
broke
broke at the ballot box yeah but
this is falling on deaf ears none of
them are listening and whoever wrote it
is probably on a short list to get
canceled immediately
they bought into this this was the
progressives issue this is what they
wanted to run on and lo and behold the
american people said no this is not how
we do things they double down they don't
change and this individual who saw the
light probably was never on board
anyways until you start seeing real
change in policy or
one of these progressive leaders come
forward and be like we made a mistake
we're wrong i feel horrible for moderate
democrats and real democrats because
they get mixed up in this and one of the
most frustrating things for me about joe
biden is joe biden was always a moderate
democrat even sometimes i felt he was
too much on crime but he gets in the
white house he beats them they need him
to get in and he just folds to their
agendas which the american people
technically didn't really vote for they
voted for him thinking he was going to
bring
balance and all he's really done is
brought these progressive agendas and
they're going to blame it on him instead
of changing the mindset and at least
admit the wrong at least say hey
we made some mistakes first world
problems
aren't the same as real problems and
they just willingly not this yeah good
for you bro but there's no one coming on
along with it lawrence is it too late
for biden to shed the woke
um yeah it's too late it's too late to
even pivot and change the issues uh
look i i use this analogy a lot because
i think it's the perfect example of
what's happening in the country
i go every single week go to diners and
i talk to middle america let's face in
the country and then i go back home and
i go to my barbershop which is the
center of all politics and black america
and they're saying the same exact thing
so
when you have the president that have
lost both groups you know it's he's in
trouble and it's not just wokeness it's
the failure to address the day-to-day
issues that are facing the american
people meyer flores should be an example
for the republican party and she did
something that no republican is able to
do she loves her country and she loves
her community as well and what i mean by
that she didn't change who she was she
didn't put on some fancy suit she talked
about her heritage she talked about the
immigrants there she talked about the
food she also talked about the crime the
border and her and she also said that
she was proud to be an american if
republicans can replicate that model
every single district where there's a
swing district they'll win not only in
hispanic america but also in black
america because they're waiting for
those leaders i'm from arizona so i
think myra flores probably makes some
really good tacos that's right i bet
she's a good cook judge
look
the dems are so focused on cultural
issues they're never going to apologize
they're never going to say we're sorry
uh and and i was i was reading an
interesting quote here
latinos are fed up former radio mombi
host dania alexandrino told fox news the
democratic party prostitutes the vote of
the hispanic population they use it they
abuse it and then they discard it they
do it every single election cycle i
don't like to segregate the hispanic
population they are people who have
needs who have concerns who are care who
are fearful of crime who worry about gas
who worry about buying chicken and how
much it is this week you know i'm tired
of the separation i get the subcultures
i respect the subcultures in this
country but at the same time you know
what the democrats it's too late for
them not to be woke joe biden doesn't
know if he's awake or unawake so he
can't he doesn't know if he's woke or
unwoke okay he can't make the transition
for all though i i think that uh the the
hispanics particularly katie are
innately conservative they are socially
conservative in many many ways they are
faith-based they're family oriented
as reagan said famously back in the 80s
their
republicans they just may not know it
yet but i think that the reason it is
significant
and the reason i think hispanics can be
carved out is that as the largest
minority group in the country there is
no way the democrats can win without a
substantial minority i mean majority of
uh hispanics and if the if they if they
have lost if joe biden and company have
lost latinos as now appears likely then
i think they they're doomed the party
going forward they they if the
democratic party is not the party of
various ethnicities what is it exactly
yeah this is party of the woke right